sometimes we just need a good cry so
having already done my list for scariest
and funniest Doctor Who episodes I
wanted to touch in some more highly
emotional moments that the show has
given us so I decided to tackle satis
now you may have noticed those previous
episodes were funniest or scary episodes
this is saddest moments I'm gonna
explain that real quick when I did my
list for funniest and scariest I made it
clear at the front that I wasn't talking
about was scariest or funniest
individual moments but rather they had
to be episodes where a scary or funny
element was a recurring persistent thing
across the episode maybe not necessarily
the predominant not necessarily the only
element but it had to be there as a
through-line
so that was what I came in wanting to do
for the sad moments but honestly as I
started to break into it and trying to
find you know pervasive sad things
across the episodes I realized well
actually most of the really sad moments
the reason they hit as hard as they do
is because you kind of don't seem coming
or you're not expecting them or the rug
gets pulled out from under you so really
doctor who doesn't do the episode that
is sad across the whole thing it doesn't
beat you down with misery that's not
what dr. who does you can go watch
Walking Dead if that's your bag so this
one is going to be sadist individual
moments of course I will be mentioning
the episodes and the context in which
they appear and I need to interject
right here and clarify I'm talking new
era Doctor Who from series 1 starting
with Christopher Eccleston Ford I'm not
dealing with classic here and as with my
funniest and scariest list this is going
to be subjective as heck what really
gets to you emotionally and makes you
sad makes you cry is incredibly personal
possibly even more so than those other
two lists were so while I a fully
acknowledge there are many sad moments
that may have hit many other people much
harder and but are not on this list I'm
not saying they aren't sad in that they
don't work but ultimately this is a list
of what hit me the hardest so that this
is
my list about me my life my history my
baggage which in an odd way is gonna
make this a bit more of a personal
psychological dive than I had intended
oh well let's get on with it anyway
starting with number 10 mieze back story
so as I said this is all very personal
and in my case the fact that I am a
parent factors into more than a few
entries on this list and getting the
backstory of his shoulder or me however
you want to refer to her played by
Maisie Williams getting her backstory in
the woman who lived and understanding
everything that she is lost across her
time of basically not being able to die
but still having these full lives and
having children and losing those
children and the pain that she was able
to express in both telling that story
and in the actual visual flashback that
were given of her mourning her losses to
me I thought was very powerful and just
in a couple of moments gave me a very
good understanding of where she was as a
character at the time the doctor was now
encountering her because she was a very
different character from when we last
saw her but just that little bit of
visualized and explained tragic
backstory to me made everything clear
and also kinda hit me personally number
nine the death of River Song in the
forest of the Dead so this one is a
little bit of a cheat and that's part of
the reason that it's lower on the list
then maybe it would have been otherwise
but also when you're talking about River
Song you kind of end up having to break
some rules so the reason this is a cheat
is this was not a particularly highly
emotional moment for me when at first
air if I still you know I felt like oh
that's sad but it didn't like really get
to me only on rewatch is having gotten
to see what went on with River later or
for her earlier and getting to know her
and loved her as a character personally
I do I know not everyone does but I like
River a lot so at this point going back
and rewatching that episode that moment
hits me much harder than it did before
and if you consider that unfair I don't
care it still hits me really hard so I'm
gonna talk about it I think a big part
of it for me
is just this kind of realization that
she has that she is going to die but
then also this this combination of
sadness and acceptance because when the
doctor says you know time can be
rewritten and she just lashes out at him
not those not those times not one word
don't you dare it is this moment where
she realizes that everything that she
has experienced that has made up her
life that she loves it has led her here
has led her to her death but even
knowing that now and this is then she
does not want any of that change not any
of it and I find it a really interesting
empower and emotionally powerful moment
because usually when you get characters
getting some degree of acceptance of
their fate it's usually comes with a
sense of peace and she has a little bit
of that at the end but we don't lose the
sadness and the fact that she's scared
she's scared about what's gonna happen
but she would still rather have it end
like this and have the story be what it
was that she'd experienced then lose
that and I find that touching and
powerful and sad number 8 from doomsday
a wall apart but worlds away this is I
think like many sad moments also I think
funny moments as well this comes down to
the performances and and I think David
Tennant does a good job of just because
the doctor has experienced loss before
and I don't mean to underplay what Rose
meant to him but he's experienced loss
of this scale before and so his
expression of just again having to deal
with this and but then her desperation
pounding on this wall with the tears
streaming down that that is a strong
moment because she just she would do
anything in that moment to get back on
that other side of the wall and that
shot where it just it looks like they're
on two sides of a wall it looks like
they're so close but they're not and
they won't be and they can't be again
ultimately they would be again but you
in the moment you didn't know that
I find that moment more powerful than
the actual goodbye on the beach which
still good moment but that moment with
the wall
oh that hits you number seven
Vincent still died I think Vincent and
the doctor maybe one of the best and
most thorough and most enlightened
depictions of depression that has been
put in a fictionalized televised form
and it's an episode that I honestly did
not really appreciate when I first saw
it I never disliked it but it didn't I
didn't get it when I first saw it I
watched and what that was okay but on
rewatching and ivory watched it more
than a few times at this point watching
what he struggles with watching the
doctor and Amy connect with him and
ultimately Amy oh so convinced that
there's gonna be all these new paintings
in the gallery and getting in there and
realizing he still died he still took
his own life and they couldn't save him
but the doctor saying we still added to
his pile of good things and that when
you're it's this idea of when you're
dealing with someone with that kind of
situation personal mental emotional
situation with depression with things
like that there may not be a happy
ending but that does not invalidate what
you had with them and what you gave to
them so it's very powerful it's very
touching it's very sad and it is
incredibly honest about depression and
what it can feel like to care about
someone who suffers from it and may
succumb to it number six from turn left
Donna realizing that she is going to die
there are a number of moments in turn
left that
are milked for emotional value I would
say overly so honestly I'm not as big on
this episode overall as a lot of people
are but there is a moment that really
hits me and and part of this cuz
spoilers Donna's gonna show up on this
list again but part of it so part of it
is that Donna is my favorite companion
so I really connect with her and when
she is pained I really do feel it
possibly more so than any other
companion but there is the moment when
she is being sent back in time across
dimensions whatever it is that she is
it's all being activated and she says oh
I understand now I'll go back and change
this and I'll be alive I'll live and the
look on Rose's face that just in the
silence and the lack of response and the
weight of everything and it's in its in
Catherine Tate's face this realization
that she is going to save the world but
she she won't be saved with it not this
incarnation of Donna
at any rate and that that moment that of
hope and white that she thinks she sees
just getting snuffed out with that look
from Rose is that's brutal number five
Donna being pulled out of the artificial
reality in forest of the Dead told you
she was gonna be on here more than once
and again this is another one that
speaks to the fact that I'm a parent and
there's a lot of stuff that I yolks
I saw everything before I was a parent
and it didn't hit me as hard as it does
now on the rewatch so seeing Catherine
Tate's performance when she's speaking
with her children in this artificial
reality and they start to say to her you
know we feel like when you're not here
that we'd
exist and it's dawning on her two things
are dawning on or the first is the
realization the confirmation that this
is all false and it's not real and in
conjunction with that the realization
that that means these children real or
not that she loves that with as much as
any mother could love her children are
going to disappear as she comes to
better understand that they're not real
it's it's just gonna keep slipping away
and there's nothing she can do about it
and you can see she's trying so hard and
then they're just gone and she breaks
down and that kills me when that happens
I find that incredibly tragic number
four the doctor can't save bill from the
doctor falls this is the closest one to
being a through-line
strain throughout the episode as opposed
to a single moment but I still think for
at least for me it culminates in a
single moment because I think all the
stuff with Bill in this episode of the
times in which we see her as a Cyberman
or we see her as she would want to see
herself as she still kind of envisions
herself going back and forth seeing the
way that people were smiling to I think
all that is very well handled and yeah
and you do feel the emotional weight of
that but I think everything culminates
in the moment where she's talking with
the doctor and she says you told me you
could save me were you lying and he
answers no and she asked were you right
and he says no this realization because
they I think it got a not necessarily
overplayed but it was built up during
mass myths there you know the doctor
lies that and you know and you had
moments like in the girl who waited
where he could be ruthless and so the
idea that he just lied to her you know I
can fix this when he knew he couldn't
that's you know that wasn't out of the
realm of possibility but to realize when
he said it he believed
did but now he knows he's wrong that's
doubly tragic because that is hope that
he had given to Bill and he had given
honestly to her that he now has to take
away after he himself had to come to the
realization and he has to he has to look
at her and admit to her face I can't fix
this and the weight of that on both of
them it's not played for as heavy a sad
moment as some of the other moments on
this list but for me it it felt like a
real just a real sinking of the spirit
for both of those characters that I
think was delivered very well number
three from a good man goes to war Amy
losing the baby this one is very similar
to other moment with Donna from a couple
of spots ago and I I honestly couldn't
tell you why this one hits me a little
harder then that one does but it's very
much for the same reason ie I I have a
parent and there's there's something
about her crouching and huddling and
holding to protect this infant and you
know she is she was there being the
protective caring mother and in an
instant it's just gone everything she
thought she was defending and protecting
is just gone and her reaction and she
screams and she did a really good job of
capturing the shock the pain it felt
different from Donna's pain Donna's pain
and I'm not saying one pain is more
impactful than another but I think it
distinguishes it in terms of the moments
Amy's pain felt more like the pain of a
stillbirth or a miscarriage whereas
Donna's felt more like the loss of a
parent whose children they had for some
time and
they are they are they impact characters
differently and I I even knowing that
difference I I don't know if that's part
of the reason this one hits me harder
but I think it's just I think it's just
the moment at which it happens it's it
is such a rug pull whereas maybe the
Donna moment was more you see it coming
and you know what's gonna hurt me see
coming
whereas Amy it just out of nowhere maybe
that maybe that's the difference but
yeah that one hurts number two Wilfred
Mott trying to give the doctor a gun
this one is really hard to articulate
why I choke up every single time I see
this I well it's partially hard to
articulate it's hard to dissect how
about that because I think it comes down
to Bernard Cribbins performance as Wilf
and that he is choking his way through
these lines trying to give the doctor a
weapon and knowing that he probably
knowing the doctor won't take it but
just desperately wanting to help to do
anything he can to keep the doctor alive
and that he can't even get through the
sentence without starting to cry and
starting to blubber and that that
performance and how deeply will feels
the impending loss of David Tennant as
the doctor and I think personally that
that that moment is more powerful than
when the doctor actually saves him and
you know sacrifices himself so wolf can
live and he ends up dying ayat this
moment of him trying to give him the gun
is much much more lump in my throat
chokes me up than then later
again maybe it's the build-up versus
more of an in-the-moment thing because
it does feel like Wilfs breakdown and
tears weren't weren't built up to they
just started hitting him in that moment
and then they end up hitting me
and that's kind of that's kind of it and
finally the number one saddest moment
for me in New Era Doctor Who to date is
the Mindwipe of Donna from journey's end
and again it's down to performance it's
down to Catherine Tate and in in many
ways it recalls when River dies and she
she snaps at him you know don't you dare
change a thing
Donna Donna makes the same choice that
River does which is that she would
rather die having experienced what she
experienced then live and lose that the
difference is the doctor takes away her
ability to make that choice for herself
he makes that choice for her regardless
of what she wants and her begging her
shaking her head saying no no please as
he goes in to remove every memory of
what she had experienced with him and
her knowing it's coming in her begging
him not to do it that that is brutal and
that just kills me every single time it
and and most of these moments I've
talked about are things that now hit me
harder as I've gotten older as opposed
to when a lot of them first aired the
this is one that this this was hard when
the first era it's probably gotten
harder since then but this is one that
even even on first viewing it really got
to me and it stuck with me and it is in
my estimation the saddest moment
modern-era Doctor Who that's my list
this has been dour this has been not
that much fun but I'm still glad I did
it so what are your thoughts on these
saddest moments of Doctor Who if you
want to give a classic error example by
all means go for you want to give your
own top ten you want to save things you
think should have been on my list
whatever you want to do drop your
thoughts down in the comments let's talk
about it don't forget to like subscribe
check me out on Twitter at council of
geeks give a listen to the council of
geeks podcast that's available on itunes
and stitcher I'm also one half of the
punch like a girl podcast that is a
presentation of the fire and water
podcast network available fire and water
podcast.com and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]